que la campagne présidentielle bien
évidemment les derniers évènements de
campagne les derniers meetings est
l'événement de la campagne hier hier
soir c'était ce meeting de jean luc
mélenchon le multiplex mélenchon le
retour de l'hologramme jean luc
mélenchon simultanément dans 12 villes
de france alors physiquement il était à
lille mais ces militants ont pu le voir
ils ont pu aussi l'entendre également à
albertville besançon le havre metz
montluçon narbonne nice pau poitiers
trappe evans jeu si toutes ces villes
parce que c'est un record à l'échelle
mélenchon il a fait cinq villes de plus
qu'en 2017 le meeting a été conçu de
manière à ce que chaque français se
trouve à environ moins de deux heures en
voiture de son propre mélenchon le
candidat a prôné notamment la rupture
avec le système il y avait des accents
comme ça de françois mitterrand dans son
meeting il s'en est aussi beaucoup pris
à marine le pen écoutez le
écoutez vous au les fâcher qu'elle pas
facho à la fin il s'avoue même cette
histoire de porte d'essayer porter cette
femme au pouvoir
oui trouvez-vous quoi que ce soit dans
ce qu'elle dit ou ce qu'elle fait qu'ils
ne soient pas entièrement teinté
d'une sorte de mai puis de classe
le pen mélenchon c'est une tasse en
finale 1 si on en croit
si on en croit les sondages une place en
finale qui est en jeu combien de
personnes ont entendu ces paroles commun
de personnes ont assisté à ce meeting un
peu particulier difficile à dire environ
8000 personnes étaient à lille en
présentiel peut être aussi entre 1000 et
1500 personnes ensuite dans chacune des
autres villes ça fait pas mal de monde
entre dix et quinze mille personnes on
va dire ça comme ça c'était peut-être le
tout dernier meeting de jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon 71 ans au
mois d'août 3e et peut-être donc
dernière campagne présidentielle mais
sur la forme fectivement c'est important
c'est un peu un spectacle c'est un peu
un show ce meeting en inde dans 12
villes ça ça peut compter ça peut avoir
un impact électoral je pense que ça
intéresse pense que des gens sont venus
voir pour voir un meeting en hologramme
maintenant je pense que les électeurs
sont 20 ont conscience de l'importance
de leurs votes et vont voter sur le fond
des projets donc ils vont avoir écouté
mélenchon et hier soir il est aussi
l'émission sur france 2 avec tous les
autres candidats je pense que c'est ça
qui est en train de mûrir dans l'opinion
publique et ce sera ça qui sera décisif
plus que à mon avis les mulets riahi la
peine
annick est ce que tu es en train de
faire un meeting dans douze il est ce
que ça peut donner une dynamique est ce
qui peut marquer des points à 5 jours et
hier soir parce qu'à partir du moment où
vous êtes partout c'est une très bonne
idée d'avoir fait ça il faut pas qu'on
soit pour ou contre le discours qu'il
tient c'est une excellente idée c c'est
très bien il nous avait déjà surpris à
la dernière élection
bon ce qui compte quand même c'est le
contenu du discours
c'est d'une pauvreté 1 signant chez
mélenchon
voilà c'est ce qu'il faut dire
c'est une un aboiement permanent mais
est on en a eu un exemple là d'ailleurs
bon on peut lui retourner le compliment
sur ce qu'il dit de ma de marine le pen
il est dans l'art de la même veine je
dirais donc mais bon la méthode des
gones moi je trouve pas que j'en ai que
mélenchon à bois est soit très agressif
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est pour ça
qu'il fait un bon résultat je pense que
les électeurs les résultats oui on va
voir du réseau unique dans les sondages
et je pense qu'ils ne pourraient pas
rassemblé s'il était sur le mode de
l'agressivité qu'on a pu dû connaître
pareil on a au contraire il peut essayer
d'avoir un discours accessible à tous
ces jeux et je dirais même que marine le
pen a bien compris également qu'elle ne
peut pas accéder au second tour et être
vous avez raison qu'il faut il faut
quand même qu'on tombait présent de la
république avoir une posture de
rassemblement des français on peut pas
être agréé il a défendu ses seins au
tout dernier moment parce qu'il a il a
justement si sa grande erreur à mon avis
c'est qu'elle elle a compris après
l'élection de 2017 quelles fallait qu'il
fallait qu'elle se recentre ce qu'elle a
fait contre l'avis d'ailleurs de tous
ses conseillers comme eric zemmour est
arrivé dans paysage et qu'il était
candidat ses conseillers lui a dit bon
vas tu es en train de te faire piquer ta
place tu te radicalise ce que tu
reprennes autant
elle n'a pas changé elle à risque
d'ailleurs
et christine jean marie le pen cette
analyse est au contraire lui s'est
radicalisée après 2017 alors qu'une
unité en position de rassembler la
gauche et là il nous fait le gentil ce
qui n'est évidemment pas dans les
derniers jours parce que bon
si tu embaucherais assez évidemment est
chez l'un et chez l'autre une posture on
viendra sur marine le pen temps mais sur
jean luc mélenchon pas vous dites aussi
vous chiappa il n'y a pas de fonds dans
le discours c'est ce que vous nous avez
dit je sens qu'ils sont disposés change
sans arrêt ils changent sans arrêt je
veux certains témoins qui sont
l'immigration sur l'immigration il dit
rarement la même chose sur beaucoup de
sujets il est et puis bon il est
complètement hors des je dirais hors de
raison sur le sur le front économique
alors je crois qu'il a reconnu lui même
avoir évolué sur certains sujets et
notamment précisément sur peut-être
cette question de comment on intègre les
émigrés en france et donc il a bougé sur
ce terrain là il a mis en avant son
concept de créolisation ses dires il a
dit la france est métis et elle le sera
de plus en plus et c'est et c'est très
bien ainsi donc sans il a évolué sur ce
terrain là par contre je pense qu'à des
constantes dans le discours de jean luc
mélenchon depuis depuis dix ans qu'il
est candidat à l'élection présidentielle
d'une part la préoccupation écologique
c'est lui qui a mis en avant la notion
de règles verte c'est-à-dire qu'on ne
dépense pas plus on ne prend plus pas
plus à la terre qu'elle n'est capable de
donner donc ça c'est quand même un
concept fort qui date de dix ans et puis
la préoccupation je dirais dur partage
des richesses également est assez et et
l'autre élément constitutif on peut pas
dire que jean luc mélenchon ne soit pas
clairement identifiés dans ses positions
dans son discours politiquement on sait
bien où ils se trouvent à la gauche
gauche et à l'écologie comme ses
collègues c'est quelqu'un qui ondule qui
évolue énormément qui évolue qui voulut
pas qu'ils changent souvent le pied
d'ailleurs il dans la posture il se fait
gentil après il est méchant il veut
faire le grand méchant donc c'est
quelqu'un qui est assez particulier dans
ceux de ce point de vue je suis d'accord
je vous accorde que sur les plans
écologique et d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
qu'il fait assez mal d'ailleurs aux
candidats écologique me semble-t-il même
si c'est un discours écologique et très
radical et qui me paraît complètement
impossible sinon radical il est intégré
matic je pense qu'il n'a pas
justement cette gamme ati sylla ils se
prennent matisse mais il a du mal à le
mettre en oeuvre
discours
oui c'était une visite éclair c'était
lundi visite express de valérie pécresse
autour du thème du pouvoir d'achat a été
accueillie peut-être qu'on va voir
plutôt challes chaleureusement pour ce
premier déplacement de la candidate dans
les outre-mer elle a notamment annoncé
son intention de créer une banque d
outre-mer écoutez là
dans mon projet il y à la création d'une
banque d outre-mer enfin enfin une seule
banque pour avoir un seul guichet pour
pouvoir faire un vrai plan
d'investissement pour les outre-mer en
matière d'infrastructures mais aussi en
matière industrielle
hqe est intéressant de noter c'est que
dans les outre-mers le parti socialiste
et le parti ait l'air ont quasiment
disparu en guadeloupe au premier tour en
2017 emmanuel macron avait fait 30 2%
mélenchon 24,1 françois fillon marine le
pen était plutôt loin derrière en au
coude à coude 14,5 pour fillon et 13,5
pour le pen ouais un mot quand même sur
valérie pécresse un qui était en
déplacement simon l'a dit en tout cas
fait un meeting porte de versailles
étaient plutôt réussis en tout cas en
comparaison de celui du zoo dont elle a
dit hier elle même qu'il était ratée que
ça l'avait fait trébucher dans sa
campagne est ce que c'est ça qui
explique aujourd'hui son score dans les
sondages ou est ce que le problème est
plus profond non moi je pense qu'il
restait beaucoup plus profond que ça
on pourrait en parler pendant deux ans
c'est vrai ça a été un tournant ça a
marqué un tournant au zénith parce que
on s'était dit alors qu'elle était déjà
en régression dans les sondages que ça
pouvait la relancer souvenez vous ça a
été les faits complètement inverse parce
que bon c'est vrai que ça a été un raté
complet sur le fond sur la forme plus
sur la forme que le fond pour son
électorat d'ailleurs et ça c était
évidemment un tournant mais il ya deux
choses qui ont fait beaucoup de mal à
valérie pécresse en dehors de ça la
première c'est que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'électeurs qui avaient du mal
à distinguer valérie pécresse de
emmanuel macron et
elle apparaissait plutôt comme la copie
que l'original par rapport à emmanuel
macron ce qu'ils ont dit l'ont
d'ailleurs sur l'état de la droite en
france ça c'est la première chose ça
veut dire que la droite s'est fait voler
son fond de commerce d'une certaine
façon la deuxième chose c'est que madame
valérie pécresse a fait une campagne
comme la plupart des autres d'ailleurs
je les mettrais quasiment tous dans le
même sac à part macron les émaux c'était
un catalogue de propositions on voit pas
la cohérence on va où le projet pour la
france et c'est tout problème de cette
droite républicaine c'est qu'elle
n'avait pas une identification
suffisamment claire par rapport d'une
part en plus parce qu'elle se trouve à
mi-chemin par rapport à zemmour dont
qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
l'identité est clair
c'était mieux avant pour faire court et
pas pour un maquereau ou ça sera mieux
demain
oula l'identification est claire aussi
alors que les autres c'est la gravité
c'est la médiocrité de tous ces
candidats qui n'arrivent pas à montrer
une identité claire auprès d d d
catherine vous partagez le sévère
constat distraire ah oui je pense que
valérie pécresse n'a pas réussi à
trouver son chemin donc en effet ce
meeting raté elle avait essayé de jouer
le ton martial mais cette difficulté et
les loups elle vient de loin si on se
rappelle le score de bel ami il a fait 6
% à l'élection européenne c'est à dire
que une droite qui essaye de jouer la
carte d'être hyper conservatrice et un
petit peu c'était mieux avant ben elle
s'est pris 6% c'est à dire qu'en fait la
difficulté de définir un discours de
droite un projet de droite quand
emmanuel macron vous promet du sang et
des larmes pour tous ceux qui
travaillent c'est quand même assez
compliqué et il l'a déçu comme elle le
dit il lui a piqué toutes ces idées donc
emmanuel macron rempli d'une certaine
manière ce côté là en étant on ne jouant
pas sur le registre de
l'ultraconservateur et quand bellamy a
joué le registre ultra conservateur il a
pris 6% donc la difficulté elle ne vient
pas de valérie pécresse l'avait
difficulté elle vient de trouver un
discours de droite moderne quand
emmanuel macron d'après hanter on voit
sur la ville
il faut pas oublier qu'il ya cinq ans
françois fillon avec toutes les bagages
si vous me permettez judiciaire qu'ils
avaient cuit il arrive quand même à près
de 20% oui des intentions
madrid à l'époque mm apr apparaît comme
l'héritier
je rentre de françois hollande au
premier tour ils arrivent quand même
déjà à capter un électorat je dirais
entrepreneuriale de droit pousse les
jeunes mathieu ginès
de 20% oui macron mais ces sacs les
papillons ses sensations ouais ça s'est
quand même montré alors ça veut dire
quoi même s'ils vont à depok aussi à la
forme je suis désolé quand vous avez
huige un discours qui est difficile
difficilement je dirais audible parce
qu'il n'est pas dit comme il faudrait
qu'il soit 10 on est très attaché à sa
en france malheureusement vous avez
raison parce que je dirais que la
médiocrité du discours d' emmanuel
macron ce week-end par mois je suis
tombé d'ennui devant son discours y
avait absolument rien sur le plan formel
il y avait des belles images mais les
mots les phrases le contenu ses
références poétiques mais tout ça
c'était d'un ennui et d'une pauvreté pas
possible bon ça va peut-être pas
l'empêcher d'être réélu ou d'être au
second tour donc la forme ça dit quelque
chose et moi je pense que sadique
emmanuel macron il est complètement
d'arn en ce moment il est épuisé et il a
plus de jus quoi il n'y a plus rien qui
sort mais ceci étant c'est pas ça qui
fait un candidat et une brèche qui n'est
pas tellement juge pas
bien l'autre des candidats qui soit
capable de faire ce qu'il a fait samedi
moi j'aimerais les voir à l'oeuvre et
c'était dans la nuit il avait compté oui
je me suis endormi voilà
c'est en bretagne car il était en
bretagne dans la circonscription de
richard ferrand le président de
l'assemblée nationale alors pour des
raisons de temps de parole on peut pas
diffuser un son du président candidat je
pourrais vous faire les bruitages mais
je sais pas si votre sachet qui s'en est
pris directement à marine le pen il a
accusé de complaisance envers vladimir
poutine emmanuel macron a notamment
évoqué le près de 9 millions d'euros que
le rn continue de payer un créancier
russe emmanuel mâcon qui se projette
déjà en quelque sorte un dans un
éventuel second tour face à marine le
pen des arguments en tout cas son prêt
oui c'est vrai qu'il attaque beaucoup le
rassemblement national ces derniers
jours lors de ses deux derniers
déplacements est ce que ça peut marcher
est ce que ça arrive trop tard ben là je
pense qu'il faut qu'ils se réveillent
non mais franchement on en parlait avant
cette d'entrer sur ce gâteau c'est que
moi je sens en tout cas du point de vue
de de l'audience qu'on reçoit sur le
site de regard à quel point le courant
anti macro est en train de monter c'est
celle qui mobilise en ce moment là la
vague de mobilisation elle est contre
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs on le voit
avec les courbes de marine le pen et de
jean luc mélenchon qui sont en en
ascension comme ça quand disque emmanuel
kundé comme ça où on ne sait pas quand
les cours vont se croiser mais que
marine le pen passe devant emmanuel
macron c'est possible qu emmanuel macron
soit éliminé ça je sais pas si on en est
encore là mais en tout cas il ya un vrai
courant anti macron qui se développe
dans le pays et les affaires récentes
mckinsey eux lui porte un tort
considérable et pas seulement mckinsey à
l'histoire des dés de la société qui a
été payé de 300 millions pour distribuer
pour penser comment on va distribuer
les professions de foi faut pas exagérer
croissance et le copain de macron il
récupère 300 millions faut pas blaguer
quand même il va s que le front anti
mâcon qui est en train de monter peut
l'écouter la victoire selon vous je sais
pas parce que c'est assez difficile de
lire finalement la pop est là et des
intentions de vote pour macron c'était
tout à fait bizarre il y passait quand
même 2 24% à 31% en quelques jours un il
est redescendu
craignent oui à 27 % oui est ce que
c'était que ça on n'en sait rien et il
est indécent de façon assez
spectaculaire à 27% il est quand même
encore très très haut
je sais pas c'est assez c'est assez a
c'est orange premier
tour le premier tu pourrais sarkozy
s'est il n'avait pas de dire est qu il l
est il avait fait une campagne à céline
et hier on a été dans une campagne très
linéaire à l'époque et il était pas
sortant l'aï les sortants n'oubliez pas
que s'il est réélu c'est la première
fois qu'un président sortant est réélu
sans sortir d'une cohabitation c'est
quasiment un exploit en france où on a
quand même le réflexe kleenex qui
pourrait encore se vérifier à cette
occasion
contre attaque marine le pen marine qui
donne une interview ce matin dans votre
journal le figaro yves je suis prête
personnellement et politiquement à
gouverner dit elle je n'aborde pas cette
élection dans le même état d'esprit
qu'il ya cinq ans je suis au bout d'une
forme de maturité c'est ce qu'elle nous
dise pas d'abord il faut dire que on a
sollicité tous les candidats pour qu'ils
nous accordent une interio certains ont
refusé comme jean luc mélenchon sent
d'autres ont accepté comme tous les
autres comme le ce qui figure dans le
journal aujourd'hui c'est madame le pen
demain ça sera monsieur macro hier
c'était madame pécresse avant-hier
c'était monsieur est beau tout ça pour
expliquer non mais non monsieur
mélenchon a été invité mais non mais
et pour ce qui est de madame louis alors
madame moi j'étais pas cette interview
mais elle est d'une sérénité effective
mais se pose en présidente oui mais elle
va pas se poser en autrement que quand
elle reconnaît qu'elle a mûri à
l'avancé mais c'est quelqu'un qui est
assez serein qui se présente devant les
électeurs ce qui va être intéressant
c'est de savoir si madame le pen
si elle perd cette élection est ce
qu'elle va tenir
le propos qui consiste à dire je ne me
représenterai plus c'est une autre
affaire on verra mais moi je note en
effet que le slogan de marine le pen
pour ça son affiche deux dernières
semaines ces femmes d'étape c'est à dire
qu'en fait elle considère que l'image
marine le pen est suffisamment installés
tout le monde sait où elle est située
enfin de quoi relèvent sa proposition
politique fondamentale et ce qu'elle a à
dire c'est que je suis une femme d'état
je suis prêt à gouverner oui et c'est ça
qui est sûr c'est que les candidats de
la république j'entends bien mais tant
que ça
c'était ça son point de faiblesse et
c'est sur ça qu'elle martèle et c'est ce
qu'elle dit dans sa dernière affiche
[Musique]